vous à tous merci de nous retrouver à
sur public sénat à suivre ce matin sur
notre antenne à l'audition d'andré
claude lacoste président de l'autorité
de sûreté nucléaire
il a été auditionné cette semaine par
l'office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques
devant les parlementaires andré claude
lacoste a expliqué que le démantèlement
de la centrale nucléaire de fessenheim
pourrait prendre 20 à 25 ans
ce sont des opérations longues at il
expliqué même si on parle de
démantèlement immédiat je vous rappelle
que le gouvernement entend fermer la
plus vieille centrale nucléaire de
france d'ici à la fin 2016 tout de suite
donc retour sur cette audition bonne
matinée à tous monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs chers collègues
avant de commencer cette audition
vous savez je reconnais que la recherche
française a été récemment honoré d'un
prix nobel de physique décerné à serge
haroche de l'école normale supérieure du
collège de france pour ses travaux dans
le domaine de la physique quantique et
avec jean yves le déaut mais nous sommes
entretenus au téléphone
nous lui adressons au nom de l'ensemble
des membres de notre fils un courrier de
félicitations
venons en maintenant à ce qui nous
réunit aujourd'hui nous nous retrouvons
pour la cinquième année consécutive à
l'occasion de la présentation du rapport
annuel d'activités de l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire la dernière fois cette
audition prévue par la loi du 13 juin
2006 avaient eu lieu dans un contexte
très particulier puisque c'était juste
après l'accident de fukushima
à l'assemblée nationale le 30 mars 2011
vous en souvenez certainement si le
contexte est aujourd'hui plus serein
qu'alors il demeure marquée par
l'accident japonais
il y à bien un avant et un après
fukushima s'agissant de la sûreté
nucléaire dans cet événement nous a
amener à reconsidérer nos certitudes je
rappelle que l'office a fait part de ses
préoccupations dans le cadre des travaux
de la mission sur l'a6 sur la sécurité
nucléaire la place de filière et son
avenir dont christian bataille et moi
nous ont été rapporteur et qui a donné
lieu à deux rapports en juin puis vient
descendre à ce rapport maire de temps
finalement
nous avions alors exprimer nos
préoccupations relatives à différents
aspects matériels et humains de la
sûreté et demander notamment une gestion
plus rigoureuse de la sous traitance la
joue une arrière-garde à la défense en
profondeur
l'amélioration des dispositifs de
gestion de crise et la garantie d'une
cohérence des évaluations
internationales de sûreté
l'audition d'aujourd'hui sera l'occasion
de faire le point sur ces problématiques
post fukushima
et d'évoquer aussi la situation de la
centrale japonaise elle même quelques 18
mois après l'accident
nous procédons cette année à cette
audition avec quelques semaines de
retard et en conséquence qui est la
conséquence du calendrier électoral de
ce dernier mois le rapport annuel de
l'autorité de sûreté ayant été publié le
28 juin dernier vous profiteront donc
aussi de cette audition pour vous
interroger sur des sujets d'actualité je
pense évidemment par exemple aux
conséquences de décisions annoncées par
le seul présent à public de fermer la
centrale nucléaire de fessenheim d'ici
2016 ou encore aux bilans des tests de
résistance européens
cette audition est ouverte aux
journalistes qu'ils pourront poser leurs
questions après celle des parlementaires
mais avant de vous donner de vous
entendre sur ces sujets monsieur le
président je voudrais saluer le travail
remarquable que vous avez effectués
depuis 20 ans au service de la sûreté
nucléaire puisque vous quittez et vous
quitterez bientôt vos fonctions qui en
vertu de la loi ne sont pas
renouvelables en temps
d'abord que directeur de la sûreté des
installations nucléaires puis directeur
général de la sûreté nucléaire et de la
radioprotection
et enfin depuis la loi du 13 juin 2006
en tant que président de l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire vous avez contribué à
renforcer temps l'exigence et la
dépendance que la transparence et la
crédibilité du contrôle de sûreté
vous avez aussi oeuvré à la
collaboration entre les autorités de
sûreté à l'échelle européenne et
mondiale et contribuer à la
reconnaissance internationale des bonnes
pratiques françaises
enfin vous avez maintenu constant et
vivant le lien avec l'office
parlementaire dans sa fonction
d'éclairage scientifiques et
technologiques du partenaire les potes
du parlement nous en avons nous en
sommes donc reconnaissants et vous
remercions très chaleureusement mousse
ou lacoste et monsieur le président je
vous laisse la parole
merci monsieur le pen ont tout d'abord
je redis ce que nous pensons très
profondément c'est que c'est pour nous
en même temps un devoir et un honneur
que de travailler avec parlement
parlement dans son ensemble certains de
ces commissions et du christ rythmant
l'office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques
deuxième point où il avait tenu des
propos aimables à mon endroit je vous en
remercie troisième point je me permets
de vous corriger sur un tout petit point
vous avez salué le collège des
commissaires de la scène au complet sauf
que nous ne sommes que quatre
le cinquième d'entre nous philippe jamet
se trouve en finlande est ce intéressant
de savoir pourquoi il est en finlande et
en finlande parce qu'il est le chef
le team leader le chef d'une équipe qui
pratique lui reste à des pratiques un
audit de l'autorité sûreté finlandaise
c'est donc une des manifestations des
systèmes par laquelle entre autorité
sûreté entre pairs nous nous évaluions
donc fils jamais conduit cette mission
cette mission va conduire un rapport qui
sera rendu public comme a été rendue
publique il ya maintenant quelques
années le rapport correspondant sur la
scène comme sera rendu public le rapport
d'audit que
la scène va recevoir en 2014
or jean vient sauver cette audition
marquée par le fait que parler notre
rapport annuel et est un peu décalé et
nous avons prévu de débloquer au
principal trois points que je vais
m'efforcer de traiter en une quinzaine
ou une vingtaine de minutes
les trois points sont les suites de
fukushima que vous l'avez vous même
apporté la poursuite d'exploitation de
l'installation nucléaire et le domaine
du médical
alors d'abord des suites de fukushima je
leur ai d'abord localement les
installations sont revenus dans un état
considéré comme acceptable par nos
collègues japonais et le sujet
maintenant et la gestion du post
accidentelle qui va prendre des
décennies
je viendrai tout à l'heure sur un autre
angle l'effet fukushima dont la plupart
des pays nucléaires du monde ça
consistait à lancer ce qu'on appelait
des stress tests est elle de résistance
que nous devons appeler en franc d'el
évaluations complémentaires de sûreté
pour oshima très grosso modo c'est le
cumul d'agressions externes en
l'occurrence un tsunami un tremblement
de terre qui a abouti à des pertes
d'alimentation électrique totale à des
pertes d'alimentation en eau qui
aboutissent à une crise qu'il faut gérer
dans tous les pays du monde et restait
consistait pour les autorités de sûreté
après des questions suivantes o
l'exploitant il survient des phénomènes
naturels extrêmes inondations ou
tsunamis tremblements de terre froids
extrêmes températures extrêmes comment
et datation réaliste hôtel première
question
deuxième question pour ces motifs
d'agression nature à l'externe tout
autre motif
il ya perte d'alimentation en eau ou
père d'alimentation électrique ou les
deux comment et l'installation à l'us
open mais troisième chose somme de l'ue
sont graves
comment est il possible déjà électrique
alors ceci a été fait dans la plupart
des pays du monde
ceci a été fait en france et ce qui a
été fait en france à demandes
simultanées du premier ministre françois
fillon et de
de l'union européenne du conseil
européen les demandes ont été émises fin
mars un cahier des charges est élaboré
en commun par l'ensemble autorité sûreté
européennes dès la fin mars a été
réalisé et dans l'ensemble des pays de
l'union européenne
les études ont été menées alors que
plusieurs stades demande de l'autorité
sûreté ou d'exploitants d'évaluer la
réponse aux questions que j'ai indiquées
rapport des exploitants ces exploitants
sont soumis à l'examen des appuis
techniques de l'autorité sûreté sont
exhumées examen des groupes permanents
expert en france le groupe allemand
espère ont été réunis pendant trois
jours unis plus de 100 personnes avec
car corporation d'un bon nombre
d'experts étrangers de toutes les
origines
et puis finalement prise de position de
l'asn au tout début de l'année 2012 2012
l'ensemble des documents ne repose
exploitant les avis en francs de l'airé
scène les avis des groupements experts
la position de leur sel sont totalement
public ils ont été rendues totalement
public au fur et à mesure qu'ils étaient
connus et ceux que nous l'avons dit nous
assène au début d'année 2012 c'est que
les installations nous paraissait offrir
un degré sûreté suffisant pour qu'il y
ait pas matière à fermer aucune d'entre
elles dans l'immédiat mais et c'est
vraiment le complément de la première
phrase qu'il y avait matière à les
renforcer pour qu'elle résiste mieux aux
agressions que je viens de mentionner ça
c'était une création attention et puis
ça s'est traduit par une rafale de
décision que la reprise à la fin du mois
de juin une trentaine de décisions par
installations ce qui a conduit à une un
petit millier de prescription s'ils
essaient de dire quels sont les deux
prescriptions principal en faisant un
résumé très abrupte elles sont les
suivantes
le premier c'est l'instauration du
concept de noyau dur ça coûte ça diable
dans chacune la station il faut définir
un sous-ensemble de matériel un
sous-ensemble de prescription qui
résistent autre procédure pendant qu'ils
résistent quelle que soit la gresser
externe envisagez donc un noyau dur
un concept nouveau
et la deuxième chose c'est la mise en
place d'une force d'action rapide par
edf dire en quatre endroits du
territoire
positionné des personnes compétentes du
matériel capable d'intervenir en secours
sur le site
tout ceci se mette en place j'ajoute que
là je parle au principal ce qui s'est
fait en france mais le rapport français
comme le rapport de nos collègues de
l'union européenne a été soumis à un
processus de peer review de revue par
les pairs processus extrêmement lourd
qui a abouti au mois d'avril donc
l'ensemble des rapports nationaux ont
été soumis à l'évaluation de les uns et
des autres avec nous encore injection
d'experts venus venu extérieur et tout
ceci aboutit à une prise de position
conjointe de l'ensemble l'autorité
sûreté et de la commission européenne
sur un papier à double en tête qui
s'appelle déclaration commune de drague
et de la commission européenne et shaw
direct qu'à ce stade là il est apparu
onu étions parvenus à un accord sur un
certain nombre de suites à donner aux
travaux il fallait mettre en place des
plans nationaux
la france c'est tentant de le faire et
puis avec quatre grandes idées qui ont
des lits retournés au plan technique
pour nous le travail était terminé et je
dirais que c'est là que nous avons
commencé à avoir un certain nombre de
difficultés avec la commission
européenne qui nous a demandé de mener
des visites supplémentaires
l'installation alors en france devra
accepter des visites supplémentaires
une installation qui était cattenom et
fessenheim est grave et nous voyez dumas
de la station frontalière
bon ces visites ont passé de façon tout
à fait ouverte ont donné lieu à un
satisfecit de la part des personnes qui
ont participé à cette visite
nous attendions à ce que l'ensemble du
processus continue à se dérouler de
façon je dirais que correcte et est
normal et n'auront été très surpris de
voir tout récemment donc au début du
mois d'octobre la publication dans les
conditions étranges d'une position de la
commission européenne
cette position la commission européenne
ne correspond à aucune nouvelle valeur
ajoutée technique il n'y a eu rien est
intervenu sur le plan technique depuis
le mois d'avril est à nos yeux ça
correspond à une lecture partielle et
est biaisée des conclusions auxquelles
le ton parvenu en commun avec la
commission mois d'avril pour un exemple
le rapport était approuvé conjointement
par la commission en string prend en
compte quarante cinq critères la
communication de la commission prend en
compte onze critères dont on ne sait pas
comment ils ont été sectionnés et pour
prendre l'exemple la france la
communication de la commission ne prend
en compte ni le concept du noyau dur ni
le concept de force d'action rapide tôt
et on a une vision tout à fait biaisé
nous avons nous autorités de sûreté
nucléaire française publié un communiqué
que je qualifierais de modérer nous
engagions de l'observation à faire
vis-à-vis la communication de la
commission parce que nous souhaitions
pas entamé une lutte ouverte mais je ne
cache pas que je suis extrêmement déçu
par le comportement de la commission qui
me paraît mettre tout à fait en cause le
minimum de confiance qu'il faut avoir
pour travailler ensemble et je crains
une autre vie en situation de l'amo
connu historiquement une situation où
nous ne pouvions pas nous autorités de
sûreté au sens large du terme en europe
travaille en confiance avec la
commission mais encore une fois bonne 11
ans à l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est que
l'élévation complémentaires sur telle
tristesse ont été menées qu'ils ont
abouti à des décisions et que ces
décisions vont être appliquées et vont
renforcer la sûreté nucléaire en france
ou en forte la sûreté en europe
j'ajoute qu'à nos yeux ceci n'est qu'une
partie du sujet une autre partie du
sujet qui n'a pas encore été traité et
celui de la gestion d'un accident en
europe et la gestion du post
accidentelle fukushima est survenu au
japon il ya été gérée par une autorité
japonaises et la distance entre le japon
et les autres pays a ajouté au sens du
vent a fait que très rapidement est
apparu qu'il n'y aurait pas de
conséquences de fukushima no d'autres
pays supposons qu'un accident majeur
survient en europe est tout à fait
évident que nous aurions dû faire face
cette situation qui impliquerait un nom
important de pays alors
les différents pays sont ils préparés à
gérer une situation de crise du genre
fukushima en europe puis de la
préparation et la gestion
post-accidentelle dire que là dessus il
ya une certaine avance de la france en
matière de réflexion sur le post
accidentelle nous assènent les viandes
demandé au premier ministre en 2005 de
nous confier une mission d'infection se
poser une antenne en 2005 c'est-à-dire à
froid c'est une réflexion qui implique
maintenant plus de 300 personnes de
toutes origines les les différentes
administrations des élus locaux des
associations des savants et qu'il
l'amène à faire des propositions au
gouvernement
tout ce qui a été fait d'ailleurs en
toute transparence tous les documents
préparatoires ont été rendus publics
nous avons me semble t'il une certaine
avance le stade avancé a maté réflexion
mais il est clair que c'est un sujet
extrêmement des pieds à faire partager
par les autres pays ce culte embrayant
sur des l'habitude nationale et que pour
ne prendre qu'un exemple le ministère de
l'intérieur n'ont pas une énorme
habitude de coopérer en matière de
gestion de crise nucléaire
c'est un sujet ouvert voilà ce que je
vais te dire sur fukushima
deuxième sujet c'est le sujet de la
poursuite d'exploitation de
l'installation nucléaire
vous savez quel et réglementation et la
législation en france la loi dit que les
installations tiers sont autorisés à
fonctionner tant qu'elles sont sûres
il n'y a pas de limites quantitatives
fixé dans les l'autorisation ils sont
donnés aux installations contrairement à
six panneaux d'autres pays simplement
soulcié soumis à contrôle c'est à dire
que périodiquement balle exploitons
novell fixe prestation est sûre puis
elle vérifie que l'autocratie fiq
l'autorité sûreté doit vérifier que
l'installation fonctionne et ça nous le
faisons moyens d'inspection q2 mais
impulsion par an nous venons au moyen
des gamins dossier et puis nous faisons
à travers une procédure qui est une
procédure lourde mais que je crois tout
à fait efficace
questel des examens périodiques de
sûreté en anglais périodiques safety
review
donc tout est mise en examen au fond de
la sûreté d'installation est l'occasion
de ce réexamen nous faisons deux choses
et nous forçons épatant à faire deux
choses
première chose vérifiez que
l'installation est conforme aux règles
qui s'appliquent à l'aise et c'est une
installation est conforme à son
référentiel de sûreté
et puis deuxième chose examiner les
conditions dans lesquelles la sûreté de
l'installation peut être renforcée ça
veut dire si je prends l'exemple d'un
réacteur 900 mégawatts se demander ce
qui peut être fait pour rapprocher la
sûreté de ces tracteurs somme à gwatt
lui assure t deux acteurs plus récents
comme acteur très sonné grotte où le prc
lui pas du tout de dire la sûreté doit
devenir équivalente à celle d'un café à
mais que peut-on faire pour améliorer la
sûreté
donc il y est procédé tous les dix ans
ça nous conduit par exemple actuellement
à examiner les conditions dans
lesquelles directeur de 13 100 mégawatts
il y en a une vingtaine en france
peuvent continuer à fonctionner au delà
de 20 ans ça nous amène à garder les
conditions dans lesquelles les réacteurs
de 900 mégawatts sur l'a34 peuvent
fonctionner de l'a30 puisse à présent
d'un pris position sur trois réacteurs
dans l'ordre tricastin 1
fessenheim 1 et budget 2 et puis nous
apprêtons à prendre parti sur une suite
d'autres acteurs dont la fin de cette
année au plus tôt début d'année
prochaine fait 100 m2 alors dans chacun
des cas nous imposons un certain nombre
d'améliorations et nous disons le
recteur à nos yeux peut continuer à
fonctionner dix ans où il peut
fonctionner dix ans avec un rendez-vous
intermédiaire où nous pouvons tout à
fait imaginer dire ils ne peuvent au
mieux cinq ans où nous pouvons imaginer
de dire il faut arrêter cas par cas nous
prenons la position et la loi dit
réclamant que c'est à nous de prendre
position
le gouvernement se borne à prendre acte
de notre position c'est ce que nous
avons fait encore une fois trois fois
c'est ce que nous ferons prochainement
sur fessenheim 2 je doute que il me
paraît avoir dans le monde une
distinction très claire entre les pays
qui ont cette politique de examen
périodique avec la vision d'un progrès
continus en matière de fürth
et les pays qui n'ont pas cette
obligation de l'examen périodique et qui
ont une vision des choses dans laquelle
le but est non pas de faire progresser
sûreté mais de maintain sceptiques
maintenir en sûreté nous sommes
clairement dans une optique ou la sûreté
doit s'améliorer à chaque opportunité
j'ajoute que tout à fait lire ceci quand
une installation bien à s'arrêter il
faut donc avoir une politique active de
démantèlement en france la politique de
démantèlement qui a été suivi une
politique de démantèlement immédiat - hi
media ne doit pas trop impressionné
immédiat ça veut dire qu'on commence dès
que possible
on ne joue pas à mettre les
installations tout con sous cocon en
attendant des jours supposés meilleurs
pourquoi démantèlement immédiat c'est
pour profiter du fait que il y à des
exploitants qui savent ce qui s'est
passé l'installation si pour profiter du
fait que les provisions existe et que
des provisions ne sont pas dépensés
risque d'être détournés à d'autres
usages tout un meeting ce jour donc
politique active de démantèlement à
mettre en oeuvre voilà pour la poursuite
d'exploitation de la station nucléaire
est mon troisième point je l'avais
annoncé cesser le médical en particulier
la radioprotection dans le secteur
médical alors le prénom à souhait c'est
que l'autorité sûreté nucléaire
française est une des très rares
d'autorité dans le monde qui s'occupe de
radioprotection d'un secteur médical il
ya très très peu de nos homologues qu'il
fasse je voudrais évoquer trois points
le premier point est l'accident
ils m'ont et modérée de radiothérapie
d'epinal alors je vais le faire avec
prudence dans la mesure où la sanction
judiciaire est en cours et epinal est un
drame effroyable
non seulement parce que une douzaine de
personnes sont mortes et parce que aussi
bien ces personnes que incertum
survivants vivent des souffrances
absolument intolérable un taux des rats
derrière epinal bien certain nombre de
cause le comportement des rats d'auteur
peut être mettre surtout un phénomène
qui nous est apparu qu'ils à phénomène
générique c'est à dire le manque de
radiophysiciens en france manque cruel
et nous sommes intervenus dès que le
pouvoir leur était donnée pour dire
qu'il emportait de renforcer le système
des radiophysiciens en france il ya eu
des progrès des produits sont encore à
faire mais je pense que sur ce point là
il faut constater effectivement l'effort
qui a été fait ona d'epinal quel est
l'état de la radiothérapie en france il
ya à peu près 180 centres de
radiothérapie en france nous les
inspections une fois par an nous alors
l'inspecteur du point de vue qui est le
nôtre c'est à dire l'organisation les
procédures la présence de personnel
qualifié
nous avons été amenés à suspendre le
fonctionnement n'a somme de 100 de
radiothérapie c'est une décision très
difficile parce que ça consiste à
laisser le traitement se poursuivre pour
les patients en cours de traitement
ça consiste à interdire l'entrée de
nouveaux patients dans le cursus de
soins ça veut dire qu'on oublierait
patients dans l'état où ils sont allés
se faire soigner dans des lieux parfois
éloignées au prix de transport très
difficile dans c'est pas une lésion
commandes mais à partir du moment où
nous considérions qu'un sens de
radiothérapie ne fonctionnait pas dans
les conditions correctes
nous avons conseil s'était auto board
suspendre la situation s'est très
nettement améliorée il ya eu des efforts
d'organisation pense que nos inspections
ayant beaucoup concouru il ya
l'augmentation du nombre de
radiothérapie donc la situation s'est
améliorée mais nous continuons à suivre
de très près
et puis le troisième point sauvé c'est
quelque chose qui est un souci prêts à
long terme qui est la croissance des
expositions reçues par les patients dans
le monde médical et pour deux motifs un
premier motif cette une augmentation
générale de lui l'âge de l'imagerie
médicale alors mejri médical la
radiologie pour ça c'est le terme
général en fait le heat a fait domaine
là dedans c'est une utilisation
croissante des scanners et le scanner de
plus en plus pointues
et pour nous il ya toujours un chiffre
que nous avons en tête c'est un scanner
corps entier fait bénéficier le patient
d'une dose de l'ordre de 20
millisieverts c'est à dire l'équivalent
de la dose maximale qui est admise pour
les travailleurs du nucléaire et on
trouve dans deux chroniques médical des
patients qui bénéficient au titre retire
le mot de plusieurs scanners de ce
jardin il est clair que si on n'y prend
garde
si la croissance des doses reçues par
les patients continuent à croître
elle a crû de 50% 7 en france nous
allons trouver une situation où les taux
de médicales pourront créer des
conséquences secondaires tout à fait
notable en particulier la création de
concert peut faire ensemble de choses le
formation d'information publication
prochaine d'un du guide des indications
du badge les utiliser au mieux
d'imagerie et c'est inciter ministère de
la santé installer davantage
d'installations dire m
c'est une technique alternative
n'utilisant pas les rayons x mais c'est
un effort de long terme nécessaires
s'ils vont pas nous réveiller dans 20
ans avec vraiment très grave problème de
santé publique
puis deuxième sujet lui aussi en même
temps présent à long terme ces sujets de
la radiologie interventionnelle
radiologique est utilisé par des gens
qui n'ont pas spécialiste pendant une
intervention se faisait une intervention
cardiaque d'interventions de chirurgie
rugby intervention la radio est utilisé
par le praticien pour surveiller ce qui
fait vraiment de praticiens en général
n'est pas un radiologue patentés et nous
constatons actuellement un certain
nombre de conséquences néfastes à
l'environnement ça si mystérieux dermit
enfin parfois tout à fait sévère sur les
patients parce que les appareils sont
pas utilisés au mieux ouais mais c'est
le prénom 3,3 sujet lors qu'ils
concernent des champs différents mais
qui correspondent bien sauver ou aux 200
notre activité la surveillance des
grosses installations ce que l'appelant
les grosses bêtes depuis le champ de la
radioprotection qui concerne plus
directement des individus en particulier
patients
nous sommes là votre disposition pour
toute question vous souhaiteriez de
poser merci monsieur le président je
vais vous voulez vous posez les quelques
des cotations du premier vice président
monsieur vidéo sera décerné depuis mes
collègues bien m'accorder et ensuite les
journalistes s'ils en ont moi je capte
question assez courte
la première c'est sur la gestion de la
sous-traitance et le contrôle en cascade
de sous traitance qu'on nous avions
quelque part dénoncé avec monsieur matin
ou en étant depuis le rapport de notre
mission d'information sur la sécurité
nucléaire
deuxième question la problématique c'est
important d'ailleurs il va y avoir un
débat public de lancer sur la sûreté
soulevées par la gestion des déchets
radioactifs
troisième question c'est l'impact de la
transition énergétique en parle de plus
en plus de la transition énergétique
vous serez à commencer par la fermeture
de fessenheim et sur la sûreté nucléaire
donc comment l'allemagne gère-t-elle
cette question de transition quelles
sont les questions de sûreté soulevé
lors de la phase de fermeture puis lui
démantèlement est une question
d'ailleurs corollaire un petit peu celle
là c'est la loi prévoit qu'une centrale
pourraient être mises à l'arrêt par
décret en conseil d'état après avis de
l'asn
si cette centrale présente des risques
graves ce que vous disais tout à l'heure
mais dans quelle mesure une mise à
l'arrêt est elle possible
si l'asn affirme l'existence de risques
graves
alors c'est pas une question qui se veut
polémique c'est quand même une vraie
question qui est d'actualité
voilà monsieur le président puis ensuite
que monsieur le déaut posera d'autres
questions certainement
mais ces trois questions d'abord sur la
sous traitance
c'est un sujet que nous avions déjà
évoqué lors de notre de l'audition
précédent de de l'asn
c'est un sujet complexe
non je vous attends ça phénomène
industriel tout à fait général et avec
ce fait de deux aspects de dire à une
sous traitance qui conduit à faire appel
à des spécialistes
la société n'a pas chez dans les
spécialistes qui fauche et appelle les
spécialistes pierre duhaime culture
détente qui consiste à faire il ya des
compétences plus banal mais que la
société n'imagine pas de retenir chez
elle et ça conduit si on prend le cas
d'edf au phénomène suivant à peu près
vingt mille personnes qui travaillent
chez edf en tant que salarié d'edf
il ya une vingtaine de milliers de
personnes qui interviennent en tant que
sous-traitant le plus souvent
occasionnels mais dans cet ensemble de
personnes sous traitantes vous avez
aussi bien areva qui intervient à
l'occasion d'arrêt du réacteur pour
maintenance ou pour rechargement
directeur et vous l'avez aussi bien tel
ou tel artisans qui vient avec quelques
compagnons pour des travaux qui peuvent
être des travaux de nettoyage ou de
peinture dont il est très difficile de
tenir un propos général sur la sous
traitance
nous nous efforçons de la surveiller
très largement par le biais l'inspection
et le biais les inspections porte aussi
bien sur les chantiers de façon dont ça
si parce que sur la politique d'achat
d'edf
c'est un des points edf veut quand il
veut lancer l'appel d'offres
s'applique-t-il bien à choisir des sous
traitants digne de ce nom
quel est le fonctionnement du processus
d'habilitation d'edf
alors ça c'est le point général depuis
notre dernière question nous nous
l'avons fait deux choses une première
chose a été faite par le biais de
l'arrêté que de l'aplomb dans notre
jargon l'arrêté yên bai la respecte une
installation nucléaire de base depuis la
loi de 2006 nous avons la loi de 2006
sur la transparence la sécurité en
matière nucléaire
nous avons un décret de novembre 2007
des cas général et nous avons un d un
arrêté qui portent prescriptions
générales en matière de sûreté
une des prescriptions devront ajouter à
cet arrêté est une prescription qui
interdit à un exploitant nucléaire de
sous traiter à surveillance d'un stade à
ce type de travaux importants pour la
sûreté à tandil exploitant notamment en
son sein la capacité de surveiller
correctement les travaux importants
poids sûreté au delà de ça nous sommes
en train de lancer ça avait été une
demande du hctisn 1 du haut comité pour
la transparence à ses côtés un médian
nucléaire un groupe de réflexion sur les
facteurs sociaux ruelle l humain bon
c'est largement une demande des
syndicats
le groupe s'est déjà réuni deux fois il
va seul une troisième fois et je pense
sous traitants sera non pas son seul
thème mais c'est un très très clairement
donc travaux en cours sur un sujet
encore une fois difficile et sur
lesquelles il est extrêmement il serait
extrêmement délicat d'affirmer que tout
va bien partout mais nous surveillons ne
serait que possible et me semble qu
assez clairement les grands exploitants
sont conscients de leurs devoirs
deuxième sujet déchets radioactifs hors
celui-là c'est un domaine dans laquelle
la france a clairement eu une politique
il ya eu la loi de 1991 qui portait pas
principalement soit déchets hautement
actifs qui a créé l'embarras
kafétien rendez-vous quinze ans plus
tard et c'est quand même une chose très
remarquable permettrait cette remarque
de citoyens de voir le parlement se dire
qu'un an plus tard il nous faut une
nouvelle loi est votée la loi 15 ans
plus tard remarques de citoyens donc à
une nouvelle loi en 2006 mais qui
constate les progrès faits dans le
domaine la définition la politique aux
actes
l'existence d'un plan national de
gestion des matières et déchets
radioactifs pngmdr sa marque un certain
nombre de rendez-vous sa fille que la
ligne à suivre sur la gestion des
déchets trop d'activités avec la
perspective les créations à stockage
souterrain et périodiquement
nous mettons un jour le plus ancien des
gestions de matières radioactives qui ce
qui se déroule un des points les plus
importants c'est clairement la gestion
des déchets de très haute activité qui
doit se dérouler suivant un programme
qui a été établie quitte à ce que ce
programme s'arrête si des obstacles
importants se dresse l'étape la plus
récente a été la décision du
gouvernement de lancer un débat public
sur la perspective de créer un stockage
souterrain aux alentours de bure ya ce
débat public il ya la préparation d'un
rendez-vous dans parlement qui est celui
de la préparation de la loi qui définira
ce qu'elle leur verse ibilité aussi tout
ceci vence dans des conditions positives
deux rendez vous suivants et le dépôt
par l'andra d'un dossier de demande
d'autorisation de créer un stockage
souterrain qui sera soumis à
autorisation du gouvernement
mais ce qui me paraît important c'est
que une fois ce processus se déroule
dans un contexte où il ya une
répartition claire des responsabilités
entre le gouvernement et le parlement
parlement ayant au fond et deux
décisions les plus importantes
les questions de la réversibilité projet
doit prochainement puis éventuellement
seul le parlement pourra décider de
fermer au terme de période de
réversibilité stockage sur un sujet ce
genre cela me paraît que le parlement a
forcément assuré des responsabilités
majeures
ça me parle terme il me semble qu'on a
qu'on a clairement une feuille de route
en quoi le processus peut s'arrêter à
tout moment mais on a eu photo
pour votre troisième question porte sur
la transition énergétique alors souhaite
s'il ya un point sur lequel la le taux
était sûreté nucléaire a été extrêmement
vigilante c'est à ne pas s'immiscer dans
la les débats soient politiques
énergétiques
parce que c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
notre champ pour nous poser des
questions plus précises actuellement je
je je serai dans évoqué deux ans
commençant peut-être par la question
relative aux au démantèlement et à la
réunion installations premier show cbs
c'est qu'un exploitant peut tout moment
décider d'arrêter son installation pour
un motif qui sont propres
simplement on peut pas imaginer une
installation restant simplement arrêté
pendant longtemps il faudrait sûrement à
qu'elle entre dans un processus de
démantèlement de l'extérieur comment
peut-on affirmer une installation ces
exploitants des sites pas le faire une
femme qui à seulement 3,3 façon de faire
c'est la meute ils la ferment la
fermeture pour des motifs de sûreté
alors c'est peut-être fait par l'asn ce
que tu as fait part de mini chargeurs
sûreté nucléaire si peut-être fait pas
le premier ministre mettant chacun des
cas il faut pouvoir arguer du fait que
ya un motif de sûreté et dans chacun des
cas l'asn à intervenir
et vous savez que dans le cas de
fessenheim 1 donc pas encore plus partie
de la façade mais nous l'avons dit à nos
lieux mais ça ne pouvait continuer à
fonctionner donc prenez outils sûreté
l'asn peu le maire n'en peux pas l'ami
charles nation et peu de mes propres
amis semaine encore faux tickets de
motifs sûreté il ya un deuxième motif
possible aux tic 2
virer la politique énergétique mais ça
suppose grosso modo une loi suppose plus
loin sur la transition énergétique
disent que pour des motifs tenant à la
politique énergétique au mix énergétique
il convient de fermer telle ou telle
installation il ya 1 3 des motifs
possibles qui est une décision prise par
l'exploitant parce que l'état les forces
l'état est actionnaire majoritaire d'edf
l'étape force et edf a fermé
quitte à ce que les actionnaires
minoritaires ou louer ou l'électricien
qui bénéficient le courant telle ou
telle station fall des encours nous il
ya une étude de voir simplement
clairement si on peut dire que la voie
la sûreté est une voie difficile ou non
fondées ça renvoie probablement à une
loi outils de la politique énergétique
alors j'ajoute quand ils vont faire le
démantèlement c'est une opération qui
prend du temps et à leur démantèlement
immédiat crois qu'il entend devoir de
voir les délais un pantalon les annales
puisque c'est quand même très largement
de fessenheim son métier qu'est il allé
votre question nous considérons que pour
que edf constitue un dossier susceptible
d'être mis en quête publique sur la
fermeture n'invoque comme personnel il
faut sans doute deux ans pour constituer
le dossier pour que l'os est soit
présentable et souhait cette seigneurie
doit pas étonner
vous l'avez peut-être vu récemment que
nous l'avons indiqué que le dossier que
venez nous présenter edf pour
démantèlement manie ce n'était pas
acceptable et ya à peu près un an nous
avons dit que le dossier que dave
présenté pour une enquête publique pour
créer une alerte ppr a pris ben brik le
dossier n'était pas acceptable
donc je vais ya une notion dossier
acceptable pour être mis en quête
publique qu'il suppose une qualité
minimale
c'est proment lors de deux ans pour le
constituer surfer 100 m
kate ensuite la durée pour aboutir un
décret de mise à l'arrêt définitif et
démantèlement contenu 2d enquête
publique contre l'ensemble des produits
à mener sans doute trois ans donc entre
le moment où edf commence à constituer
un dossier demi d'arrêt définitif et
démantèlement et moment où un décret
peut-être pris c'est sans doute de
l'ordre de 5 ans ça n'empêche pas la
mise aux arrêts
ça n'empêche pas son de l'opération qui
sont couvertes par le régime juridique
de l'exploitation passe donc
déchargement du
du du coeur du réacteur mais sans pêche
de l'opération de démantèlement
proprement dit je veux tu que si on
essaie ensuite de dérouler les dossiers
le des membres tellement proprement dit
peut sans doute prendre 25 ans en étant
surveillé on est en fait sous le couvert
du décret depuis l'arrêt définitive et
démantèlement c'est faisable une
expérience a été accumulée en france
mais encore une fois son opération
longue bien qu'on les qualifie d'
démantèlement immédiat
voilà monsieur parce que je peux
répondre en première intention aux
questions que vous avez bien voulu poser
je vous remercie et ils ont une vidéo
jeunes roms merci monsieur le président
moi d'abord je voudrais m'associer à ce
qu'a dit je n'étais pas arrivé mais j'ai
vu ce qu'il a dit à ce qu'a dit le
président sido
pour vous remercier puisque vous allez
partir de tout le travail qui a été mené
par l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire que
le parlement et l'office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologiques a très largement
contribué à créé par la loi de 2006 et
par plusieurs rapports précédents je
voudrais donc remercier de ce climat de
confiance vous êtes venus régulièrement
devant le le parlement converser les
commissaires qui sont à vos côtés
lorsque ceux de ce travail de l'autorité
avec une bonne séparation de ce qui est
du pouvoir régalien de l'état vous venez
de vous exprimer un peu sur ce sujet et
disques de ce qui est du contrôle de
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
c'était ce que nous souhaitions et c'est
ce qui a été mise en oeuvre
on les trois questions très courte puis
une quatrième en peut-être 4e la
première reprend celle de bruno sido sur
la sous traitance dans le cas de
fessenheim de l'incident de fessenheim
récent est ce que
les ouvriers qui étaient concernés et
des sous traitants parce que ça c'est
pas bien ça pas été bien indiquées et si
oui pensez vous qu'ils aient eu des des
négligences à ce sujet un sujet plus
importants et fissures sur les réacteurs
belges récente vous avez je voudrais
revenir sur la décision d'arrêt de deux
réacteurs nucléaires en belgique à la
suite de l'identification de fissures
dans leurs cuves vous avez signalé
également dans des réacteurs est donc au
tricastin notamment l'existence de
fissure est ce qu elles sont même nature
et si ce n'est pas le cas en quoi et
diffèrent et est-ce que donc on peut
avoir une évaluation différente de ces
deux cas vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
du quatrième réacteur de fukushima
certains alors je vais par vous avez
parlé du dossier dire que des événements
des événements exceptionnels pourrait
effectivement continuer a endommagé la
centrale mais certains ont parlé de
bombes nucléaires à retardement qui
risquait d'exploser dans la piscine à
combustible du réacteur numéro 4 est ce
que vous avez été contacté
quand ces articles sont parus elle reste
que l'asn
vous avez été très largement contacter
est ce qu'il ya eu des discussions avec
vous sur ces sujets et si ce n'a pas été
le cas s'il l'avait fait qu'est-ce que
vous l'auriez dit enfin dernière
question il ya un démantèlement
actuellement du cea à grenoble
ces silos et il semble qu'il ya
désaccord entre l'exploitant et et
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
est-ce que vous pouvez vous nous donner
votre philosophie à ce sujet parce qu'il
semble qu'il ya divergence de
philosophie entre l'exploitant qu'elle
ca
et l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire merci
beaucoup
mais merci pour ces questions puisque
vous vous avez parlé de ce café l'office
pour la création d'offices de la scène
j'ai tout la foule de souvenirs d'un
rapport qui porte votre nom a largement
été à l'origine de la création d'un
sénat en 1999
alors soit sous traitance et fessenheim
tout alors l'incident de fessenheim
ça consiste grosso modo en une erreur de
manipulation dans de l'eau qui gênait
c'est ce que nous ont amené à dire dont
il ya une disproportion entre l'incident
fait est vraiment rien du tout et
l'importance qui lui a été donné nous
avons publié notre rapport sur ce sujet
je passe la parole à à janvier sofitel
j'ai eu le sentiment nous n'avons
absolument pas vu d'autres intervenants
que les agents d'edf
ils sont des agents edf qui sont
intervenus donc comme le disait le
présent pour qu'on me dira d'accord
deuxième chose de le poser le problème
d'un certain nombre de défauts affectant
les réacteurs belges lors nous
connaissons bien nos voisins et amis
belges et il se trouve que l'asm à
développer les compétences particulières
sur de la rue j'ai des cuves il apparaît
pression grâce à notre direction qui est
implantée à dijon qui est la direction
des équipements sous pression
donc je vois tu es ce cd le début de
l'année ce qui se passe en belgique ce
qui semble être en cause cette la
révélation de défauts qu'ils ont sans
doute des défauts d'origine ces défauts
de fabrication quand la cuve de 12,3 a
été fabriqué par des ateliers maintenant
disparu à rotterdam
alors là ils sont en cours leurs acteurs
12,3 n'est pas près des marais il ya là
et sur tihange et des avis sur tous les
réacteurs qui ont été fabriqués par ces
ateliers rotterdam
on vient de recevoir le résultat de
wingles en suède on a reçu les résultats
de mühleberg ans en suisse non
l'ensemble des autorités regarder ce qui
se passe
j'espère que les autorités américaines
font font de même alors ce sont ce sont
des défauts sans doute due à l'hydrogène
alors que les défauts tricastin ce temps
d'une autre nature je t'ai demandé à
jean christophe de préciser donc les
cuves de réacteurs sont en acier au
carbone pour les protéger de l'eau du
chef du primaire qui est qui est bourré
il ya une couche en inox qui est posée
sur cet acier au carbone qui est soudé à
l'occasion des soudures ça peut créer
des tensions dans dans le métal au
carbone il a été constaté dans les
années 90 qu'un certain nombre de cuves
présenter des défauts des des swaps et
les défauts sur revêtement des dsr liés
à ce processus de soudage donc il a été
demandé évidemment à edf de d'inspecter
l'ensemble de ces qui vaut aujourd'hui
sur l'ensemble du parc à une trentaine
de défauts de ce type dont la moitié
d'ailleurs pour le recteur de tricastin
1 et donc sécu font l'objet d'un suivi
régulier et notamment d'un contrôle à
l'occasion des visites décennales et le
ed elle doit justifier que ces défauts
sont des défauts de fabrication et
n'évolue pas en service et ils sont
surveillés comme l'accusent de tricastin
à un nombre de défauts importants lieu
d'être une inspection tous les dix ans
elle est ramenée à 5 ans donc à
l'occasion de de la durée examen de
sûreté qui a eu lieu récemment il a été
fixé un rendez vous dans cinq ans à edf
pour faire un nouveau contrôle avec des
appareils de détection de ses soudures
son revêtement pour vérifier si les
soudures si les fissures évolué ou pas
si jamais elle évolué évidemment edf
devront tirer les conséquences
or que ce sont longues et et défauts
survêtement du nature tout autres que
ceux de 12 et dont nous avons pu faire
constater par l'examen qui ont été
menées que ils n'évoluent pas mais comme
fois ils sont sûrs ils sont sous
surveillance
et quand vous regardez les prescriptions
devront apposer à tricastin 1 après sa
troisième usine au final vous avez la
somme de dispositions que l'on arrive à
ça j'ajoute pour faire le lien entre ce
qui s'est passé en belgique et en france
qu'à présent les autorités belges ne
faisais pas le genre d'examen qui lui
avait permis de mettre en évidence et
des fous survêtement en france
l'autorité belge a fait ces examens en
belgique et c'est à l'occasion de ces
l'examen des fourrures vêtements qu'elle
trouvait cloud beaucoup plus grave elle
approfondit si l'investigation et c'est
là qu'elle est tombée sur les défauts
qui affecte 12 et qui sont sans doute
des défauts due à l'hydrogène
son talent ya tout de même des fausses
merci à des jeux copiés pas d'ombré sur
le la piscine du réacteur de fukushima
soit qui est présenté comme une bombe
nucléaire à retardement t ne sommes pas
l'autorité de sûreté japonaise nous
sommes en contact extrêmement régulier
avec nos voisins avec nos voisins de
course
nos collègues japonais nous les voyons
au moins une fois tous les quinze jours
en france à vienne ou récemment à
toronto les piscines ont été renforcées
il n'y a pas de problème spécifique sur
cette piscine alors j'ai pas été
interrogés dernier point c'est le
démantèlement du cea grenoble savez
j'avais déjà eu l'occasion de dire ce
n'est que parmi les grands exploitants
que nous contrôlons celui avec lequel
les rapports sont souvent plus difficile
celle ci a peut-être vous souvenez-vous
qu'une décision question avait été posée
par un de vos collègues visant à
l'évidence les rapports doivent être
difficiles avec edf même temps que le
marché
l'équité est ouvert et que des f est
privatisée je vais lire apple pie vi
avec le ceva qui à ma connaissance
t'es pas semer un marché ouvert et
n'était pas privatisée nous avons invité
directement qui porte sur le degré
jusqu'auquel il faut tout nettoyer le
site sur lequel est implanté silos et
c'est un sujet sur lesquels nous avons
pris parti le second n'est pas content
mais c'est l'état du maire du ceva
très bien merci christian bataille oui
monsieur le président la coste je veux
moi aussi joindre ma voix à celle de mes
deux collègues pour saluer le travail
que vous avez accompli jusqu alors j'ai
sans doute cette caractéristique à
l'intérieur de l'office d'être vu le
nombre de rapports que j'ai signé ou
cosigné sur votre sujet est celui qui a
le plus qui vous a le plus sollicité je
veux vraiment vous remercier d'avoir
toujours répondu avec courtoisie à nos
sollicitations et d'avoir souvent
éclairé les élus que nous sommes plus
que nous sommes des élus politiques et
nous n'avons pas la science infuse
besoins des éclaircissements à la fois
législatif et est surtout technique
alors moi je veux saluer votre modestie
parce que je vivais sur l'idée que au
fond vous déteniez un pouvoir technique
et que la décision d'arrêter une
centrale relevé de l'autorité de la
scène et de l seul et que le pouvoir
politique au fond n'avait pas un avis
très pertinent sur ce sujet je vivais au
fond sur l'idée qu' il appartient à
l'asn de décider la prolongation de
l'activité d'une centrale ou sa
fermeture pour des raisons techniques et
que le pouvoir politique de son côté qui
a lui aussi un pouvoir est plutôt sur le
versant de la définition et de la mise
en oeuvre d'une politique énergétique et
je veux saluer votre modestie parce que
dans la réponse que vous
effet à bruno sido tout à l'heure vous
avez dit oui on peut arrêter
effectivement une centrale pour des
motifs de sûreté mais vous avez aussi
évoqué la décision prise par
éventuellement edf mais si je comprends
bien des feux n'est pas sur la vie de
décider d'arrêter des centrales qui sont
autorisés de continuer mais vous avez
ouvert une porte en disant mais bon il
peut y avoir la définition d'une
politique énergétique à travers la loi
mais je vous remercie d'avoir salué le
rôle du parlement en la matière dans le
domaine nucléaire c'est sans doute un
des domaines où finalement le parlement
s'est acquis un véritable levier depuis
une bonne vingtaine d'années et au fond
a plutôt l'avantagent par rapport à à
l'exécutif dans ce domaine alors je
voulais quand même vous demander votre
sentiment maintenant que au terminer
votre carrière active
en espérant que vous resterai toujours
en éveil pour éclairer de vos avis vous
avez dit l'asn ne fait pas de politique
en gros 1 en résumé donc la scène se
tient à distance du pouvoir politique et
le pouvoir politique lui même s'il ne
veut pas altéré la crédibilité de la
scène doit se tenir à distance
de l'asm alors vous avez de nombreux
critères de comparaison internationaux
je voudrais vous demander comment vous
concevez la relation entre la scène et
et le pouvoir politique au fond où
s'arrête votre autorité et où commence
l'autorité du pouvoir politique choisir
sais c'est pas simple de définir sa un
quidam peut réagir en disant qu'après
tout c'est le président élu et le
parlement élu qui ont tout pouvoir
un quelqu'un qui est plutôt technocrates
aura tendance à dire bon après tout
cette affaire relève uniquement de la
vie technique de l'asn
alors je vous répète ma question non
seulement on regarde de la situation
française mais par rapport à à des
comparaisons internationales comment
quelles leçons tirez-vous
en gros de la mise à distance de
l'autorité politique et de l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire
ma réponse sera la suivante une autorité
de sûreté nucléaire doit exercer
pleinement les responsabilités qui sont
les siennes mais les responsabilités qui
sont les siennes sont de responsabilité
de sûreté il ya un pays où ce qui est
exprimé assez clairement dans la loi
c'est l'espagne s'est exclamé un peu
sous forme d fait clic et le
gouvernement ne peut pas être plus
laxistes en matière sur tech l'autorité
oui si l'autorité dit non c'est pas
possible maintenant papa dire ce oui
c'est possible mais si auto était dit
oui c'est possible gouvernement peut
dire non je ne veux pas et mutatis
mutandis est un tout petit peu c'est
vrai ce que le point que nous
l'évoquions tout à l'heure si vous
remplacez le gouvernement par papin par
le parlement et la noix donc nous notre
rôle
et demi déjà que nous le dire nous dire
non ou d'être capable de lire non au
delà mais il ya notre part jusqu'à
présent eu un refus tout à fait
catégorie d'entrer dans les débats
énergétique
là il va y avoir un débat sa transition
énergétique et je pense nous serons
amenés à intervenir pour une raison que
je peux dire nous ne pouvons exercer
notre contrôle sûreté nucléaire que si
nous sommes effectivement capable de
dire non
nous sommes capables de dire il faut
fermer ou nous fermons telle ou telle
installation
mais il n'est pas si fermé
l'installation que si le système de
fourniture électrique la capacité de
fourniture électrique en france est
suffisante
je dis souvent c'est qu'une des choses
qui nous nous interpelle c'est la
situation où la france est obligée de
choisir entre sûreté nucléaire et
fourniture d'électricité donc que notre
âme nadir d'en débattre à 36 transition
en attique c'est que pour que nous nous
assurions à sûreté nucléaire il importe
que la fourniture des inscrits en france
soit garantie par des moyens fiables des
permanents avec des marges suffisantes
pour nous permettre encore une fois
d'exercer la sûreté nous avons des
exprimés sweet quand la cour des comptes
a mené son enquête sur le coup les
coulisses christ en france meurtrie
c'est écrire des lettres est clairement
non mais je pense qu'une autre femme en
disant que nous ne souhaitions pas que
la sûreté nucléaire soit considérée
comme une variable d'ajustement
si on a besoin que ça qu'on ne vont pas
se fier sur dans lesquelles si on avait
un nucléaire on accepte qu'ils
fonctionnent les conditions moins sûr il
faut que la situation soit tels que le
nucléaire ne fonctionne que dans des
conditions sûres
non pas la première fois sortir de notre
silence sur ce genre de sujet pour
éviter encore une fois que nos
successeurs à tous ici en 2025 ou en
2040 se trouve dans ce que dans 6 des
fiances youn appelle un corner qu'on est
dans l'impasse on a terriblement besoin
d'électricité
il n'y a pas suffisamment de qualité
disponibles on serait prêts faire
fonctionner son trait nucléaire cette
fois la vieille dans des conditions
acceptables
c'est ça que nous voulons pas et c'est
ça que nous ne forcerons d'exprimer dans
les thèmes qu'il faut dans le débat
intervenir l'autre que quand je parle de
fouet aux activités permanentes par les
moyens fable savais pas du tout dire
seulement le nucléaire ni même
principalement nucléaire mais il faut
qu'ils aient une capacité de fourniture
fiable et permanente ça supposerait
sûrement de l'investissement il se rend
compte que ce genre d'investissement
doit être prévu non en avance pour qu'on
trouve en particulier le financement le
porteur du projet l'investisseur
donc c'est ça de notre souci avec encore
une fois une vision à long terme dans
lesquels les problèmes que nous posons
ne sont pas des problèmes pour 2025
passe de seulement pour 2025
d'ores-et-déjà ce sont des problèmes
dans lequel il faut le demander quelle
sera la situation 2040 ou 2050 alors
nous n'irons pas au delà dans ce débat
parce que nous voulons pas être accusés
de jouer un rôle dans la politique
énergie la france c'est simplement pour
nous l'occasion et la nécessité de dire
en termes sûreté nucléaire il faut
qu'ils aient des moyens alimentation
fiable permanent et en quantité
suffisante pour que nous puissions jouer
d'autres l'autorité sûreté
patrick hansen merci beaucoup monsieur
le président je voudrais à mon tour
évidemment vous remercier et plus
particulièrement pour monsieur le
président mais aussi votre équipe pour
le travail que vous réalisez maintenant
depuis que l'asn a été porté sur ses
fonts baptismaux en fait j'ai deux
questions qui en réalité sont assez
complémentaires
la première nous concerne je dirais la
manière dont votre collège c'est à dire
vous et il est commissaire vous
définissez la politique générale de
l'asn en matière de sûreté nucléaire et
de radioprotection
si on est amené à faire un peu de
comparaisons internationales par rapport
à d'autres agences qui sont en charge de
la sûreté nucléaire
comment positionne riez vous notre asn
c'est à dire l'âge ans par rapport à
d'autres pratiques à l'international
c'est la première question quant à la
seconde question
elles portent beaucoup plus sur la
manière dont on peut envisager la
révision des normes de sûreté cette fois
ci à l'international j'ai vu dans le
rapport que vous étiez extrêmement actif
en la matière que l'asn agissait à la
fois sur le plan international et sur le
plan européen
est-ce que là vous pouvez nous en dire
un petit peu plus sur la manière dont
vous contribuez à cette révision des
normes de sûreté à l'international étant
entendu que là aussi il y a évidemment
des discussions qui portent sur d'une
part le principe de précaution mais
aussi d'autre part le degré de risque
potentiellement acceptable
donc voilà les deux points qui me qui
évidemment ne me préoccupe un peu il m'a
forcée de répondre à vos questions sur
la première question la comparaison
entre nous et d'autres autorités
je prends et d'abord le domaine de la
sûreté nucléaire
il me semble que nous jouons assez
clairement le rôle de deuxième autorité
de sûreté dans le monde
après celle des états unis celle états
unis est importante pour deux raisons
historiques pour des noms pratique aussi
l'autorité américaine comporte quatre
mille personnes
regardez 450 personnes que nous avons et
alors même qu'il n'y avait pas de
réacteur nouveau en construction
collègues américains ont créé une
direction de direct des nouveaux
réacteurs est d'emblée ils ont embauché
quatre cents personnes
quand je vois la façon dont nous nous
battons pour obtenir après fukushima 20
personnes
ça nous ça nous ça nous laisse rêveur je
n'irai pas au delà ça ne va pas
descendre continuer sur ce sur ce sujet
là mais nous ça va c'est clairement la
deuxième autorité de sûreté au monde et
on voit bien sûr mais quand ya un débat
sur un sujet difficile
très souvent les américains prennent
parties s'attendent à ce que tout le
monde s'incline autour d'eux et un grand
silence
aucune autre autorité une prendre ne
lèvent le doigt et puis c'est nous
qu'ils vont loi et que nous sommes
d'accord ou pas d'accord tu ne sois pas
d'accord comme par hasard un certain
nombre d'autorités dit oui mais on n'est
pas d'accord avec l'américain
nous sommes clairement la deuxième
autorité sûreté togo mais ça n'empêche
pas que nous avons d'excellents rapports
une quinzaine ecc
la grande différence entre nous nos
cages américains c'est que nous sommes
porteurs d'un domaine sûreté de l'idée
d'un progrès continu
eux ne le sont pas c'est une différence
majeure
nous sommes porteurs de l'épreuve
continue parce que il ya eu en france
des générations que les cibles de
réacteurs qui ont manifesté de progrès
en matière sûreté aux etats unis apple
construction pile années 80 lors
deuxième sujet la radioprotection
nous sommes très la faim dans ce domaine
là vont démarrer seulement au début de
l'année 2000 il me semble que la menace
est bien situé et il me semble qu'une
des choses qui nous différencie pas à
pas aux homologues
c'est sans doute je vais manquer de
modestie notre capacité à poser des
questions très difficiles
la croissance globale des doses dans le
domaine de l'imagerie médicale d'un
poème redoutable autre exemple que je
n'ai pas développé mais que
éventuellement michel gognau par
développer c'est le problème de la
radiosensibilité individuel
nous ne sommes pas égaux devant les
doubles au rayonnement on découvre peu
les conséquences en tirer peuvent être
immenses quand on dit que je suis de tel
ou tel traitement il ya un certain
nombre d'effets collatéraux délicats ou
difficile ça peut-être dû non pas vous
fait que le traitement est mal appliquée
nous fait qu' il ya cinq ou dix pour
cent des patients qu'ils sont plus
sensibles mais s'il ya cinq ou dix pour
cent des patients qui ont un plan cible
ça veut dire là sans doute 5 ou 10% des
patients qui sont moins sensibles et
vous voyez que ça conduit à des
problèmes redoutable d'individualisation
des traitements éventuellement de
reconnaissance l'individu c'est ce type
de problème c'est que nous allons poser
et que peu de nos homologues se poser la
question si l'on sait révision des
normes de sûreté à la tsr en particulier
après fukushima
oui nous sommes conscients du fait que
les évolutions doivent intervenir au
niveau international loria l'europe ne
les forçons de travailler au niveau
européen je crois beaucoup aux travaux
qui sont effectués collectivement de
bazens au bottom up des clubs en
particulier le club d'échecs d'autorité
en europe il ya les jo d'affaires au
niveau mondial et une lame et ils ont
beaucoup subi nous n'avons joué un rôle
important dans la news tradinaires des
parties de la convention internationale
sûreté nucléaire qui s'est tenu fin
août-début septembre à la vienne j'ai
été élu comme président de la prochaine
réunion de deux des quelque 100 pays un
kaki qui sont les parties prenantes de
cette convention
cette réunion aura lieu en avril 2014
trois emplois fukushima nous nous sommes
fixés comme objectif que nous puissions
collectivement dire donc échelon mondial
3 bat pas fukushima voilà ce qu'on a
fait un diabétique nous poursuivons
c'est de pouvoir dire effectivement
maintenant l'objectif pour une nouveau
recteur et suivants il faut prévenir
l'accident
ils rendent aussi peu pour votre que
possible et si un accident en modérer
les conséquences et en particulier
éviter des contaminations hors site à
long terme
évitez les contamines sur site à long
terme
c'est typiquement tirer la leçon de foot
chemin c'est très ambitieux pour arriver
à le décliner à techniquement mais pour
nous pour moi c'est vraiment la leçon à
tirer de fukushima rééditer un action
comme fukushima avec jean d'autres je
suis extrêmement moderne nommé pression
peu de morts directement dus aux
radiations mais avec contamination pour
le long terme d'une portion aussi
étendue territoire ce n'est pas l'équipe
que peut-on faire pour progresser là
dessus et avec un rendez vous donc en
avril 2014
c'est ça l'objectif un écran qui pas du
tout le résultat mais c'est ce à quoi
nous nous ambitionnons de contribuer
nous sommes au parc de nice merci
monsieur président oui monsieur le
président j'ai moi aussi quelques
questions
d'abord concernant le japon lorsque vous
avez été auditionné le 5 juillet dernier
par la commission des affaires
économiques de l'assemblée nationale
vous nous avez dit qu'en 2007 vous aviez
participé à une mission d'audit au japon
et que votre constat était très clair je
au site
le modèle japonais de contrôle de la
sûreté nucléaire ne fonctionnait pas
ensuite vous nous avez dit nous avons
adouci notre propos suite à des
discussions compliquées avec les
autorités japonaises
la question c'est au vu de ce qui s'est
passé depuis est ce que vous regrettez
d'avoir adouci votre propos est est ce
que vous pensez que pensez-vous de la
crédibilité de la deuxième autorité donc
de sûreté nucléaire au monde
si lorsqu'il y à des audits croisés on
adoucit les choses que l'on constate et
vous nous avez dit par ailleurs que en
novembre de l'année passée 2 en 2011
après l'accident de fukushima vous aviez
posé la question au secrétaire général
du ministère au japon qui vous a indiqué
qu'après réflexion le gouvernement
japonais avait pris la décision de ne
pas mener de réforme du système de
contrôle malgré ce que vous préconisiez
et donc comment pouvez-vous nous dire
aujourd'hui surtout si vous n'avez pas
été contacté par vos collègues japonais
que en ce qui concerne le réacteur
numéro 4 de fukushima il n'y a pas de
problème si vous pensez que le système
de contrôle japonais ne fonctionne pas
bien
deuxième élément en ce qui concerne
l'europe donc on a tous suivi évidemment
les échanges entre l'autorité de sûreté
et la commission européenne sur les eaux
cs et notamment le constat fait par la
commission européenne qu'un certain
nombre d'éléments n'étaient pas prises
en compte comme les crashs d'avion on
sait par ailleurs que le piratage
informatique où les incursions
terroristes n'ont pas été prises en
compte et donc comment peut-on
aujourd'hui dire que les réacteurs
nucléaires français sont sûres
si on ne prend pas en compte ces risques
et donc est ce que vous préconisez qu'on
prenne en compte ces risques
par ailleurs vous avez reconnu
et c'est important que six accidents
nucléaires il y avait en europe
évidemment il n'y aurait pas que le
territoire français qui seraient
concernés et donc en conséquence
est ce que vous êtes d'accord j'ai lu
cru dire l'inversé donc ça me surprend
avec le fait qu'il faudrait dorénavant
avoir une autorité de sûreté européennes
en matière nucléaire qui permettent à
l'ensemble des pays concernés par les
installations de prendre en compte les
risques
enfin troisième élément je vous avais
aussi interrogé lors de la même audition
la commission des affaires économiques
sur un anomalies génériques qui est
constatable sur le site de l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire qui date du 7 février
2011 et qui concerne 34 réacteurs de 900
mégawatts et qui indique que face à
cette anomalie le l'edf envisage de
prendre des mesures
je suis allé voir récemment pour voir ce
qu'il en était la paille resté
exactement la même
donc ça veut dire que vis-à-vis de cette
anomalie génériques
rien n'a été changé semble-t-il de la
part d'edf donc la question que je me
pose c'est à partir de plans l'autorité
de sûreté nucléaire compte elle prendre
des sanctions vis-à-vis d'un exploitant
sur le kia auprès de duquel vous avez
constaté des anomalies génériques et qui
ne fait rien deuxième élément concernant
la gestion des centrales
en ce qui concerne fessenheim puisqu'on
convient d'évoquer donc on avait indiqué
les modalités juridiques et
administratives en quelque sorte pour
une fermeture mais comme vous l'avez
indiqué évidemment ça ne dit rien du
moment auquel on arrête le réacteur
lui-même qui peut intervenir entre
maintenant et ce moment or des travaux
sont programmés sur la sûreté de
fessenheim la question qui se pose c'est
est ce que ce n'est pas un gaspillage
que de continuer à dépenser de l'argent
sur cette centrale d'autant qu'on entend
dire que la lente reprise pourrait
demander des dédommagements à l'état
donc si elle engage des travaux elle ne
manquera d'autant plus de dédommagement
donc on risque finalement de se
retrouver dans une situation où on aura
laissé faire de dépenses qu'il faudrait
rembourser
en ce qui concerne le vieillissement des
centrales si vous a été a été évoquée la
question des centrales belges et et je
voulais savoir si vous partagez le point
du président de l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire belge qui a estimé que les
fissures constatées dans les réacteurs
dans les cuves des réacteurs français et
des plus graves que celles qui sont
constatés sur les réacteurs belges
puisque certaines sont longitudinal et
d'autres transversale les nôtres si j'ai
bien compris est un transversale et donc
il disait que c'était plus grave
d'ailleurs est-ce que vous pouvez aussi
nous confirmer parce que la question du
vieillissement est évidemment une
question importante et la cour des
comptes a souligné à ceux de ce point de
vue que en termes de stratégie
énergétique la france avait
implicitement décidé en tout cas si elle
poursuivait dans l'option nucléaire que
ce serait par la poursuite directeur
existantes
bien plus que parle par le
renouvellement du parc que les choses se
feraient vu le rythme auquel se
renouvellerait ce parc
vous pouvez nous confirmer que pour un
réacteur existants la cub ne peut pas
être changé et donc dans les
possibilités de modification d'un
réacteur qui interviendrait au bout de
30 40 ou 50 ans voire même plus si si on
écoute et edf
si si donc vous confirmez que la cub ne
peut pas être changé et donc il ya
forcément un vieillissement progressif
de cette cuve et que notamment lire
essai n'ayant constaté sur plusieurs
réacteurs qu'on ne pouvait exclure des
incidents à partir de la 35e année
qu'elle ce qu'on peut en tirer comme
conséquence sur l'évaluation de la
capacité ou pas à poursuivre
l'exploitation de ces le sélecteur enfin
dernière question comme ça a été indiqué
par plusieurs orateurs
vous arrivez en fin de mandat et donc
quelles préconisations pourriez-vous
donner pour que l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire à l'avenir et plus d'autorité
encore à plus de capacité à faire des
contrôles plus de capacité à être
entendu des exploitants et à faire en
sorte que lorsque l'autorité de sûreté
et m'aider à vis des exploitants soient
obligés de les prendre en compte
merci merci pour cet ensemble de
questions je les reprends dans l'ordre
sur le japon j'étais effectivement à la
tête d'une mission d'audit l'autorité
japonaise en 2007 j'ai indiqué que nous
avions effectivement à doucier la
formulation de propos à la suite de
discussions avec nos collègues japonais
une raison assez simple si nous l'avions
sans doute maintenu la verdeur des
propos que l'avion initialement écrit
était tout à fait clair que nous aurions
eu un propos totalement rejetée par les
japonais je ne sais pas combien de temps
comme une fois vous êtes allé au japon
mais quand vous connaissez un tout petit
peu j'appelle choisi une dizaine de fois
est tout à fait clair que vous avez un
mode approche qui est tout à fait
spécifique
j'ai dit que nous devions un dossier aux
propos il avait parfaitement été compris
puisque c'est tout à fait délibérément
que les japonais ont décidé de ne pas
apporter de réformer leur système
ils en ont délibéré parfaitement perçu
ce que j'avais dit que nous l'avions dit
et en particulier le fait que leurs
autorités de sûreté et leurs exploitants
n'est pas les rapports qu'il faut eux
vous avez posé ensuite eu une question
sur les contacts à propos de fukushima
de quoi nous avons des contacts avec
tout cas je vous dis d'ailleurs j'ai cru
répond à une question pour savoir si
vous avez posé des questions si j'ai une
journée de questions c'est bien la
question quelle joie pendue nous avons
des contacts avec nos mais les japonais
nous recevons régulièrement des nos
collègues nous avons reçu cette semaine
nous recevons une semaine prochaine mais
encore une fois nous ne sommes pas
l'autorité nucléaire du japon sur ce qui
a été fait les stress tests en europe
est tout à fait évident que les stress
tests ont été bâties pour répondre à une
question
la question c'est quelles conséquences
tirez-vous de ce qui s'est passé à
fukushima 1 fukushima qu'une fois père
d'alimentation électrique agressions
naturelles extrêmes père d'aimantation
de criques perdre émanations gestion de
crise c'est à cela que l'ensemble de
l'exercice ont été bâties pour répondre
c'est à ça que l'ensemble de nous mêmes
et nos collègues ont répondu et je peux
dire que nous avons fait très bien merci
alors il s'est greffée au dessus des
questions autres mais qui n'avait rien à
voir avec fukushima du type résistance
aux chutes d'avion du type terrorisme
mais quand elle va rien à voir avec
fukushima
pour nous le propos clairs des
tristesses qu il suffit de regarder la
délibération
du conseil européen des 25 mars 2011
c'est là sur terre vous dites que nous
laisser n'a reconnu que un accident
dépasserait frontières met en avant nous
avons toujours dit pourquoi croyez vous
qu on fait des exercices transfrontalier
pourquoi croyez vous que la solution nos
collègues allemands nos collègues
suisses nos collègues belges aux dsi de
crise est évident qu'une crise grave
aurait des conséquences transfrontalière
alors il faut en tirer un tome de
conséquences
personnellement je n'irai pas je vais en
tirer la conséquence d'une autorité
sûreté européennes hic façon c'est aux
états d'en décider s'il a décidé ainsi
pourquoi pas mais moi j'ai tout à fait
en tête l'idée que le concept d'autorité
de sûreté ne marche pas toujours se
méfier des cas j'ai un exemple en tête
qui est celui des ogm
regardez ce qui se passe quand
l'autorité européenne donne son
autorisation pour que les cultures de gm
dans un pays et à garder ma façon en
somme pays central de dire non non on va
pas suivre ce qu'a décidé à l'autorité
on va aller là contre mais ça mérite un
débat plus complexes ou plus complet que
celui que j'évoque qu'une fois
s'il ya des si on crée une autorité
sûreté européennes c'est à l'évidence
par une décision des états que je ne
vois pas peindre sur les travaux sur
fessenheim et non prescrits des travaux
sur le premier acteur fait ça n'a donc
sans doute pressés des travaux sur aube
et directeur fessenheim ce sont les
travaux sur ses pieds maîtrisé dans un
temps court sur fessenheim 1 lors pris
des décisions juillet 2011 devrait peser
que les travaux soient terminés pour
l'été 2013
fessenheim a vocation à fonctionner
ensuite jusqu'à la fin de 2016 donc vous
voyez il n'y a pas de raison de retarder
les travaux dans le milieu où ils sont
faisable dans la mesure où ils sont
programmés dans la mesure où ils sont
techniquement tout à fait défini
je doute que sur fessenheim 2 ou 3 mai à
prendre des décisions sans doute du même
genre et là aussi nous n'aurons aucun
scrupule imposait de ces travaux sont
faits dès que possible
ça nous paraît dans notre ressort normal
de notre activité d'autorités de sûreté
vous avez pose la question du
vieillissement centrales souhaitent sur
les centrales cas présent il ya deux
éléments qu'on ne sait pas changé comme
s'est pas renouvelée qui sont la cuve et
l'enceinte de confinement
donc ce sont deux équipements que l'on
garde de particulièrement près c'est pas
hasard souhait si une des expertes eu
les plus pointues que nous l'avons
développée au sein de la recette c'est
les baptistes loi n'a pas la pression
sur tout ce qui concerne la cuvée
circuit primaire
donc on les regarde d'extrêmement près
on a cité tout à l'heure tricastin au
tricastin il ya des défauts sur
vêtements qui sont des défauts encore
une fois modéré reconnu qui ne bouge pas
nous savions de ces prêts qu'il est
possible mais ne savons parfaitement que
il faut d'autant plus surveillé la cuve
et le revêtement qui ne sont pas changés
enfin vous l'avez demandé ce que je
pourrais souhaiter pour pour l'asm à
l'avenir mais je vous dirais que je
trouve que le statut actuel l'asn est un
statut qui marque un progrès
considérable par rapport aux ports
intérieurs puis en particulier sentiers
de l'indépendance mais pas très
longtemps que je considère que nous
fonctionnons toute indépendance
alors bien sûr les exploitants vis à vis
du gouvernement aussi mais je vous prie
de croire que c'est plus commode de
fonctionner en toute indépendance quand
vous n'avez statut pour ça et je
rappelle qu'il ya un article de la loi
tsn qui dit que les membres du collège
ne doivent pas recevoir d'instructions
de quiconque de quiconque t-il cas ça me
paraît un acquis considérable
nous avons réfléchi à ce que pourraient
être les amendements ou un toilettage à
doigté scène je ne cache pas que à mes
yeux ce qui est sans doute le plus
urgent c'est des temps de pouvoir dans
le domaine de la sécurité
le sujet vous l'évoquiez a proposé
d'aider des chefs-d'oeuvre nous ne
sommes pas compétents ce domaine là pour
le mans le seul projet que nourrit le
gouvernement c'est de nous donner la
responsabilité du contrôle la sécurité
des sources des sources radioactives
sont utilisés dans l'industrie la
recherche avait-il voulu prendre la
sécurité
fait-on de l'occupante la sécurité mais
je pense qu'à terme comme dans
l'ensemble des pays du monde devraient
l'être en charge en même temps de la
sûreté la sécurité
c'est vraiment une des réformes
auxquelles je pense je pense en plus
mais que si on pense au long terme
il ya une vraie affection à mener sur
l'articulation des responsabilités entre
les pays européens et le niveau quant à
les pays d'europe et le niveau européen
pardon alors j'espère que les produits
génériques aux effets de la fusion mais
je pense que jean christophe barret bon
oui tout à fait en 2011 il ya eu un
niveau 2 sur edf c'était un problème de
coût cinéday des groupes électrogènes de
secours c'était juste avant l'accident
de fukushima donc c'est un problème
d'usure prématurée de ses coussinets et
donc nous allons bien sûr demander à edf
de prendre des dispositions et des
dispositions qui sont en cours
aujourd'hui qui consiste à remplacer les
coussinets régulièrement à suivre la
qualité de l'huile puisque ccc des
objets qui font l'objet d'une
lubrification et avoir une surveillance
renforcée et en parallèle edf réfléchi
pour le plus long terme avoir une
solution définitive qui ne reposent pas
sur leurs emplacements réguler les
coussinets vous permettent il s'agissait
de défaut que vous avez constaté le 7
février 2011 concerne les débits
d'injection de sécurité donc les autres
autre problème
d'accord ils sont surtout les trous sur
les 900 mégawatts qui sont les
coussinets en plus sur les je peux pas
répondre à votre question instantanément
ou fera le point où fera part de 2,2 de
la réponse
they et sur le le président de
l'autorité de sûreté belge qui aurait
dit que c'était plus dangereux chez nous
on connaît bien wild rouvert il nous
avons été les premiers qui l'a appelé
pour lui apporter aide et je crois qu'il
est parfaitement persuadé du fait que
les défauts survêtement que nous
connaissons autres et 15 passes sont
d'un ordre de gravité infiniment moins
que des défauts qu'il ya sur la queue de
doudounes et encore une fois quand j'ai
tout à l'heure que la coupe du doubs
n'étaient que 12 3 thomas près de
redémarrer mon propos un sens
merci oui mais sur président messieurs
les présidents intervenant après la
forme de mes collègues veut pas reposer
les questions qu'ils aient reçu
d'excellentes répondrais non moi
monsieur lacoste commencer par un
compliment qui a été fait par les uns
par les autres sur le rôle vous avez
joué depuis que vous êtes à la tête de
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire vous êtes
une référence tant pour ce qui concerne
la compétente que l'indépendance et
c'est un compliment qu'il va également
en direction de vos commissaire je
voudrais vous pouvez une question geek
est moins technique que cette préposée à
l'instant il y a on le voit bien besoin
d'assurer un lien entre ces affaires
compliquées que sont le nucléaire et les
industries nucléaires et l'opinion je
voudrais moment où vous allez quitter
votre votre poste vous indiquez vos
comment vous percevez la façon dont on
doit à la fois informer éclairé dire la
vérité sur le nucléaire
je m'explique dès qu'on parle de
nucléaire les gens ont peur évidemment
en particulier depuis fukushima
lorsque il y à un niveau 1 qui est
annoncé au fond une bonne partie des
français puis des européens ne savent
absolument pas à quoi ça correspond ils
ont l'impression qu'il y à des incidents
à répétition font le fait qu'on ait une
volonté transparence et vous mettre le
relais implique qu'il ya sur ce nombre
d'incidents qu'ils ont signalé mais on a
du mal en mesurer l'importance et la
gravité un moment où on parle la
transition énergétique où le débat sur
le nucléaire va va rebondir est ce que
je peux m'autoriser à vous demander au
fond comment vous envisageriez que nous
puissions améliorer la relation entre
l'opinion et et tout ce qui touche au
nucléaire
ma première remarque ce que je n'imagine
pas que la scène envisage de transiger
avec l'obligation de transparence qui
est la sienne et que lui impose que
l'imposé la loi est juste que pour nous
parmi les vertus une notion de pratiquer
et 1,4 et vendeuses par deux il ya la
compétence et rigueur d'une part il ya
d'autre part transparence et
indépendance et ne pourront pas être
indépendante il n'est pas transparent
et vice versa conçoit des communiqués et
transparente extrêmement difficile nous
nous efforçons de le faire en utilisant
un certain nombre de moyens c'est vrai
qu'ils sont les moyens me semble-t-il
les plus efficaces au quai de puissions
faire appel alors je pense que ce qui a
été autrefois appelée l'échelle de
gravité qui a été conçue impressions
mobiles qui est devenu l'échelle ines
est une façon de communiquer mais je
pense que beaucoup de nos interlocuteurs
parmi les élus les responsables de cli
les médias vous même on comprit ce que
c'est qu'un incident au niveau 1 ce que
c'est qu'un incident de niveau 2 nous
efforçons d'expliquer
j'ajoute que dans le domaine de la
radioprotection des passeurs nous avons
bâti une échelle du même genre avec les
radiothérapeutes c'est une échelle la
sns ferro qui nous permet de classer les
événements survenus en allemagne
radiothérapie et quand vous regardez les
journaux médicaux
il utilise cette échelle pour parler des
lacets tels incidents survenant de
manière de thérapie dans échelle sont un
outil puissant
un autre type 807 va notre site internet
via trois des boutiques n'avons
l'occasion de commencer à mettre en a de
façon tout à fait marquer c'est
l'ensemble de tous les réseaux sociaux
sur fukushima
nous avons fait un lourd investissement
pour communiquer cet investissement
compris en particulier sur le fait que
d'emblée j'ai été amené à dire en france
nous classerons cet accident au niveau 6
d'emblée et l'autre évènement marquant
sa a été l'utilisation des réseaux
sociaux pour émettre nos propres
messages et contrecarrait des rumeurs
naissantes
l'ours est redoutablement difficile mais
c'est tout à fait nécessaire compte tenu
de la rapidité avec laquelle ces moyens
se développent et de la rapidité avec
elle des rumeurs non fondées se propage
mais c'est extrêmement difficile est un
sujet sur lequel nous efforçons de
partager avec nos collègues vont
participer à un séminaire à madrid
récemment dans participer à un séminaire
viennent nous efforçons de partager mais
ce qui m'a beaucoup frappé c'est que sur
sept ce développement de l'importance de
nos socios de l'étions parfaite
adéquation avec nos collègues américains
nous avons décidé de travailler ensemble
non seulement sur le sujet technique
mais sur le sujet de communication
green blue
j'ai cru noter que vous parliez de 2016
contre concernant fessenheim donc
j'aurais voulu simplement quelques
éclaircissements concernant la date que
j'ai que j'ai entendu dans votre propos
est une deuxième question que je voulais
vous poser ses concernant la prise en
compte des risques que seesmic
c'est quelque chose qui à un certain
moment a retenu toute toute votre
attention je voulais savoir si vous
aviez maintenant que vous êtes voilà en
fin de mandat des propositions
particulière à faire concernant la prise
en compte des risques des risques
sismiques de toutes nos installations
personnes alors j'ai évoqué 2016
professional c'est simplement parce que
c'est la date qui a été annoncée par le
peu d'en appliquer et en ce qui nous
concerne nous c'est-à-dire l'info nous
sommes maîtres en en notre sein nous
avons préparé 10 sur les profits
d'exploitation de fessenheim 1 en
juillet 2011
nous prenons parti se poursuit
l'exploitation de fessenheim 2 sans
doute en janvier 2013 mai 2007 je me
suis borné j'étais prêt dans le public
ou le met en cause si vous voulez mais
pas moi deuxième chose que l'ancien
british mais nous considérons que nous
avons en france une doctrine claire en
matière de risque du risque sismique est
une autre hymne que nous l'avons mise au
point que nous l'appliquons qui est une
doctrine que j'appellerais déterministe
on regarde le séisme le plus fort qui
s'est passé historiquement mesure était
alors il est clair qu'ils se développent
actuellement un courant de pensée à
l'échelon international qui est un
courant probabiliste que nous le
regardons était présent avec énormément
d'eux non je n'essaye pas eu bien
d'autres fonds de réserve mais ces
contenus fait que beaucoup de nos
collègues l'utilisent nous allons
regarder ce que ça donne façon tout à
fait ouverte 1 nous avons vu des
discussions avec deux collègues suisses
nous avons organisé au printemps de
cette année un colloque
strasbourg sauf ce sujet nous allons
voir si ça peut enrichir la façon dont
nous prenons en compte et chaude
merci peut-être ces messieurs les
journalistes ont des questions posées
mes collègues sont partis mais nous
sommes concertés
nous considérons qu'il ne faut pas
mélanger les genres avec une audition
c'est pas une conférence de presse donc
nous souhaitons pas posé de questions
très bien y at il d'autres demandes de
destin il n'y en a pas il me reste donc
une fois de plus à vous remercier les
uns et les autres surtout vous aussi
monsieur le président je crois qu'on se
retrouvera bientôt pour votre départ
avec plaisir merci beaucoup pour tout ce
que vous avez dit
c'est la fin de cette audition merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi je vous retrouve
cet après midi à partir de 14h30 pour
suivre en direct sur notre antenne
le discours de jean pierre bel en direct
du congrès de la r f l'association des
régions de france bonne à tous